j'ai adoré le comportement de claire
denis et de l'autre remettant sur la
maine
alors justement isabelle vendredi donc
soit vous étiez invité à la cérémonie
des césars tout autour de la salle
pleyel
il y avait des manifestations contre
roman polanski et à la sortie vous avez
internet a été interpellé par des
manifestantes devant les caméras de
quotidiens on a les images on s'est
procuré les caméras de quotidiens des
images de côté ils regardent j'accuse
détresse mais je suis je suis je suis
ravi qu'on lance qui est été élu
meilleur réalisateur
ben on attend 5 ans j'ai été violée
parfois donc j'ai pas mal moins de neige
à leur village à genève était de
problèmes aussi importants que le reste
j'accuse dans ce film alors isabelle
c'est vrai que vous êtes incroyables il
avait le projet
bachir et comment ça s'est passé raconté
nous parce que moi quand je sors je
voulais juste gagner l'autre côté parce
que je suis invité à dîner que j'avais
accepté voilà et là je tombe sur une
jeune femme ravissante la petite roue ce
qu'on voit là qui me dit un masseur
t'inquiète pas on aura la peau de ce
violeur état je lui dis ben non moi j'ai
beau que j'ai adoré le film c'est ce
qu'on entend là et là sur instantanément
il ya quelqu'un qui crie derrière crêpes
[ __ ] et il ya une autre jeune fille
qu'on n'entend pas et qui dit derrière
tu mérite d'être violée c'est là que je
reviens et que je dis maintenant j'ai
été à toucher durant cinq ans il veut
les trois fois tant que je pense avoir
gagné le droit de dire que j'aime ce
film et ça ne méritait pas de voeux pas
du tout vu qu'ils avaient les micros de
corrida c'est moi quand quelqu'un parle
de dépasser gros monsieur je regarde les
jeunes filles regardait les jeunes
filles qui étaient en surplomb d'un
baiser qui mange ne voyait pas le micro
d'isabelle et fais-moi la grâce de
croire que je suis naturel et spontané
oui je ne suis pas encore là veut dire
regardez moi regardez moi c'est pas du
tout moi les labels vous avez été peiné
par ce qui s'est passé ou pas oui j'ai
été très peiné et pour moi cette
hystérie collective c'est pas du tout de
la démocratie de la démo de la
démocratie par dont j'étais outrée qu'on
dise il faut pas s'enflammer film de
romont félicité le film de polanski si
vous le féliciter c'est le co2 est une
de ces deux là c'est du fascisme mais
non c'est pas ça la démocratie
démocratie c'est les gens qui veulent je
suis désolé pour ceux qui voulaient pas
que le film ait eu le prix mais moi ça
ne me choque pas qu'il les eut point
barre et quand je lis les articles
lendemain je vois que c'est assez
partagés dans le parisien il y avait une
féministe des années 70 une vraie mail
f1 mais vous utilisez on mélange tout et
moi je trouve bien que fils ou un peu
c'est isabelle vous avez dit voilà vous
avez parlé à 7 jeudi vous avez dit que
vous avez vous savez c'est pas moi qui
les 10 1
vous avez une histoire compliquée oui
voilà et dont je n'ai alors je déteste
seulement une connaître dans la journée
par le paraître et l'appareil je n'en
parle jamais j'en ai jamais parlé j'ai
pas du tout l'intention va parler là si
j'avais vu qu'ils avaient co-signé je
n'aurais pas parlé